thousands of stores
[Music]
especially in the area of tech and stem
those are areas where women
really are underrepresented so we have
some programs that focus specifically on
that and
gaming and esports is one of them
there's girls every week that come out
and play in our weekly tournaments and
it even inspires me as a gamer to see
them come out with no fear
you know sometimes i'm intimidated
looking at a a streamer and
seeing this program it opens up doors
and and to be confident in yourself and
your gaming abilities
[Music]
times are changing tolerance is is
is really big acceptance is really big
and having women and and
you know just people who are not men in
these types of industries
is becoming normal it's really
interesting to see because i've
like i want to get into like the esports
industry and
not just as a gamer but as like someone
who like works like
behind the scenes and so actually going
out and like seeing like
the exact jobs that are like are like
the the intricate jobs
that goes into this entry like in
creating the products like creating
connections
and things like that and i know there's
still more that we're going to learn so
i'm really excited for that too